in this question we're going to push on
the idea of ratio division of an
interval
and have a look at this secondary idea
which is called
external division of a of an interval uh
or a line segment as they're calling it
here now this is
famously confusing so i'm actually going
to go straight to part b here i'm going
to skip over part a
if you want to have a look at how to
define a divide a line
segment internally just have a look at
the previous example
but i'm just going to focus on this one
because number one
it's quite different geometrically and
number two it opens up a bunch of other
questions uh that you need to think
through in a fairly logical way
but thankfully they're consistent with
what we've already established so let's
see if we can understand
what's going on here before we get to
the particular position vectors that we
have
let's think about what could it mean to
divide a line segment
externally well if i were to provide for
you
some point a and some point b
then to divide that line segment
internally
i don't know why i did that's so thick
let's try that again to divide it
internally the whole point is that
some point let's just call it p for
point some point p
is going to be internal to this
particular interval this line segment so
uh if we were dividing or not if we were
dividing in part one it says divide it
in the ratio one to two
then i would divide this into as we've
seen before three equal segments
and then p would be here to give me this
ratio of
1 to 2. so that's what
internal ratio division looks like
nothing too dramatic we understand that
p will be between
a and b it'll be on the inside of a and
b and that's where the internally
word comes from okay now therefore i
hope it's sort of the logic carries for
you that if that's what
internal division of a line segment is
then
external division is on the same line so
what we can do is we can imagine this
going off in
you know opposite directions for
infinity
but that point p is not going to be on
the inside
of a and b it's going to be on the
outside so what i'm actually looking for
let's get rid of this particular
one that i drew before i don't need this
divider either what i'm looking for
is some point out here or out here
maybe i'll highlight those in fact i can
just get rid of this this one there
this is where i want my point p to be i
need to find
the place somewhere along either of
these two we would call them rays
i guess because they start somewhere a
and b and then they go off in infinity
2 infinity we want to find the place
along either of those rays where p
could be that we'll still have the same
ratio
one to two but it's it's different it's
going in different directions
okay now um some of you will have
encountered a ratio division formula
within corner geometry in early years
you might have been extended into that
and um some of you will have learned
that there's kind of a shortcut way
which i'm going to deal with at the end
of this question
to be able to get to the answer um i'll
get to the shortcut
in a minute but i actually want to make
sure you understand why this shortcut
works so what would this actually look
like well
i want you to call back if you were
doing actually we'll just use this
example here if you're doing internal
line division right we're dividing
this interval a b a b internally in the
ratio
1 to 2. now what this means is you can
see because i'm
paying close attention to the order a is
first b is second
one is first two is second the question
i want to pose to you is
which of the points a and b which point
will my new point p
be closer to and if you remember from
last example we can say well since
the ratio one out of the one to two is
smaller i'm going to be closer to
the first point than the second that is
closer to a
than b right if i were in the ratio 2 to
1 then i'd be closer to the 1 that's the
b
side rather than a now thankfully
mercifully the same kind of logic
applies when we're talking about
external
divisions so when i'm trying to divide
this line segment a b
externally in the ratio one to two again
i look at the order
a comes first b comes second the one
comes first the two comes second
i'm going to be closer to a than i am to
b so when you have a think about which
one of these rays i'm going to be on
which one of these rays is closer to a
than to b
and the answer is what's this left hand
one it's the one coming out of a
if you picked any point over here along
the ray from b
you would always be closer to b than to
a so you're not going to get the ratio 1
to 2
you would get a different one so we'll
get to that different one later on but
for now what you need to know is
i'm looking for that point p that i'm
going to position right about
there such that
you get this ratio one to two when
instead of going
say ah like this instead of going one
and then here comes two one to two
i now have to go outside of this
interval a b
so instead of going in the same
direction i'm actually going to have to
go
first in the opposite direction from a
to p that would be my one and then i'm
going to go from p
over to b that will be my two so
this is the one to two ratio that i'm
after now and
having found that we can now work out
where um
p will be on the basis of um geometry
and now i just need to crunch the
numbers of this
particular a and this particular b
all right so now that you've got a
handle on what external division means
let's go ahead and try and find
this answer this is part b that we went
straight to
in order to find where this is hopefully
you can see
that in order to get from a to p it's
backwards to going from a to b so in
fact i just need to find this
a p vector is just the opposite of the a
b
vector um same magnitude opposite
direction so in order to find out what
ap is first i need to find out what a
b is so let's go ahead and do that a b
is equal to o b take away o
a and i've explained the geometry and
the um
the relationship between the sides of a
triangle to get to that pair of vectors
what is ob or what are ob and oa
i'm going to get i'm going to put this
all into one step i'm going to get
5 5 and negative 8 from ob and then what
i'm going to do is i'm going to subtract
all of these so that gives me minus 2
plus 1
plus 2. you're noting that i've flipped
around the signs of the negative 1 to
negative 2 because i'm subtracting
what's that going to give us well looks
to me like i'm getting
3 and then 6 and then negative 6 so me
just double check
those signs looks good so that's a b
so therefore i can say ap will be the
opposite of that so i guess that would
be negative 3
negative 6 and then positive 6 and
because what i'm looking for
is the coordinates of p the way to get
to p
directly is from some origin to a first
and then go over
to p in other words i'm just going to
put it here
what this implies is that o
p starts from o goes to a first
and then goes from a over to p because i
know what each of those vectors
is i've got o a up the top there 2
negative 1
negative 2 and then i'm going to add
this
yeah that'll do um add negative 6
and then i'm going to add 6. so what do
i get here
2 minus 3 is negative 1
minus 1 minus 6 is negative 7 and then
i'm going to get a positive
4 down the end that's op which means
therefore that p
has the coordinates negative 1 negative
7 and then
4. okay so that's how to do the external
division
of a line segment it is a bit weird
because you've got to think about this
whole going outside business rather than
going inside
the interval but this leads to that
shortcut by the way
you can actually use a ratio division
formula if you've learnt one i don't
i don't i'm not a fan as you guys know
of learning formulas without knowing why
they work but if you have a think about
what is happening geometrically here
another way that you can do this is just
to say well this is the same as doing
negative 1
because i'm going backwards as it were
and then positive 2.
so if you learn a ratio division formula
and some textbooks will provide it for
you
you can just simply say it's the same as
doing a regular
internal division but just making the
ratio
one of the numbers negative in this case
negative 1 makes the most sense because
that's going backwards
and then forwards in the original
direction
so that'll give it to you but i also
think it is really important to know why
it is that that works
now lastly i do want to talk about it's
not addressing one of these questions
here but i want to give an example of
what it looks like
to divide this line segment externally
still
but where the ratio is opposite so
suppose let's just call this part c
if i can write that if we divide a b
externally that needs to be said
and instead of going as was asked here 1
to 2 what if we went 2 to 1
right 2 to 1 would mean when i again
pair up
this particular interval a b in that
order with the ratio
a and b you can clearly see which of
those two points you're going to be
closer to
the 1 is smaller so therefore you're
going to be closer to b than to a so if
i go back to my diagram
up here let's just grab this whole thing
and i'll delete off the parts i don't
need
so here is my a b situation
and i'm wondering where will p b in this
case
i need to be closer to b than i was to a
so i'm going to be on this ray rather
than the other one
the two to one comes from starting from
a and going all the way over
in the big jump first we'll call that p
that's going to be the two
and then the one comes in the opposite
direction
like so i should put that one underneath
just to be a little clearer
right so in this case once you find a b
you're still going to need to do that
what is the most sensible way to get to
p well because p
is over here it's closer to b it would
stand to reason that the easiest way to
get o
p would be to start at
b get from the origin to b and then go
from b
to p however in this particular one
because the ratio is
2 to 1 that means that if i just grab
this
color here hopefully you can see
that b p if i were to go from here
to here it's the same direction
and the same magnitude as going from a
to b it's just a different displacement
vector it's
starting the tail is starting at a
different spot starting at b instead of
starting
at a so therefore if this is a b
then it stands to reason that this is
also
a b same direction and say magnitude so
therefore
um to find out where p is you just go ob
and then you'd add
a b because these two vectors here
are going to be identical to each other
so hope that makes sense
if there's one tip i can give you for
all these questions even though i sound
like a broken record
please draw yourself a really clear
diagram because you can see
how much of my argument was based on
what was happening visually
and in fact all the arithmetic and stuff
like that that happens afterwards
is it's the easy part it's quite
mechanical you don't have to think very
much for it
and in fact most people will get this
part wrong not because they don't know
how to do vector arithmetic
but because they choose the wrong
directions to go in or they position p
in the wrong spot
rather than over here or they choose the
wrong
you know scalar multiple of a
of a vector to multiply by because they
don't know
how far they need to go whether it's
one-third or two-thirds or where you go
double
that kind of thing so do yourself a
favor draw a big diagram and you
shouldn't find these two questions
these questions too difficult